[Applaudissements]
gabriel burridge jeunes ex leader
étudiant de 36 ans succède à sebastian
pinera dans le palais de la moneda à la
tête du chili
il aura la tâche difficile de répondre
aux revendications des chiliens
mécontents qui ont été le cauchemar du
président sortant depuis 2010 9 dans les
rues de santiago est partout au pays il
ya beaucoup d'attentes autour de cette
voie qui les suscite de la curiosité
personnelle quand même
[Musique]
la gauche est encore une fois au pouvoir
et le choix du cabinet du nouveau
président indique que le pays s'engage
sur des voies nouvelles sur les 24
ministres 14 sont des femmes dont i
squillaci thiès à l'intérieur et à la
défense une petite fille du président
salvador allende renversé par le
dictateur augusto pinochet c'est
d'ailleurs dans la maison de salvador
allende que s'est tenue la première
réunion du cabinet ou sa petite fille
maya dit qu'elle a toujours aimé le mot
socialisme
[Applaudissements]
d'abriel boric rassure la droite et les
milieux d affaires en nommant aux
finances le président de la banque
centrale
beaucoup de thèmes qui sont très
importants pour les chiliens
et où la patience a ses limites
le nouveau président se dit convaincu de
pouvoir répondre aux changements
structurels que demande la majorité des
chiliens tenemos la conviction des mains
sa manière aux tirs ennemis et il n' a
demandé qu'on laisse ces changements
dépendront de la proposition attendu en
juin d'une nouvelle constitution par la
convention constitutionnelle est lui
sous le président pinera pour calmer la
révolte populaire
la session de la cour du plan qui va
suivre pour être décisif
le gouvernement boric ne dépend pas ni
ça va être en tous cas un vote il faudra
gagner pour
cette nouvelle constitution devrait
remplacer celle héritée de la dictature
pinochet qui a accru les inégalités qui
minent la vie des chiliens
jean michel leprince sera du canada
montréal